two ships arrive in the port of his
Cameroon in southern turkey in them
nearly 400 portable homes from Qatar
they were used to house fans during the
World Cup in the Gulf State now they'll
provide shelter for those affected by
the earthquakes last month in turkey and
Northern Syria
more than a dozen other ships are on the
way with more prefabricated houses
qatar's ambassador to Turkey says many
more are coming
in
this ship there are almost 400 houses
this is the first batch of 10 000 houses
from the first day we continue
supporting our brothers in turkey and in
Northern Syria we hope this will be
suitable for the earthquake survivors
the portable houses are fully equipped
and will be placed in the affected areas
in Turkey the United Nations says that
at least 1.5 million people have been
left homeless because of this earthquake
they're now living in tents in container
cities but also in trains like this one
we have heard that around 1 000 people
are living here
like many other areas in the
Southeastern part of the country is
Canada was devastated by the earthquakes
families leaving in the train say they
have nowhere else to go and it provides
shelter and protection from the cold at
night
says she's living here with her three
children hi Allah May no one ever see
such a knight again it was hell everyone
left their homes in a hurry to survive
there was no building undamaged we have
been here for a month now we don't know
yet how long we'll stay here but if they
close the trains we'll have to go to the
tents
says her husband works for a railway
company and that's why they came here
a house is damaged this is my husband's
workplace we have come here to find
shelter we are grateful that they have
given us the train cars
rebuilding devastated areas is a
priority for the Turkish government but
it will be a while before people are
able to move to a new home that's why
providing some form of housing now is
crucial to help those who have lost it
all
[Music]
turkey